presidential making history becoming the
first American president to ever step
foot on to North Korean soil for a
meeting with kim jeong-hoon thus
restarting nuclear negotiations and the
effort to get the regime to dismantle
their weapons arsenal
here's the president touting the
progress made between the two countries
we've developed a great relationship I
really think that if you go back two and
a half years and you look at what was
going on prior to my becoming president
it was a very very bad situation a very
dangerous situation for South Korea for
North Korea for the world it was an
honor that you asked me to step over
that line and I was proud to step over
the line I thought you might do that I
wasn't sure but I was ready to do it of
course the president's visit met with
fierce criticism here's Trump's 2020
Democratic rivals they're casting doubt
on the meeting despite three years of
almost bizarre foreign policy from this
president this country is no safer when
it comes to North Korea they have
launched other missiles flouting the
diplomacy that this president has
attempted so far so we've added
legitimacy to Kim jong-un it's worrisome
that this president erratically sets up
a meeting without the staff work being
done it seems like it's all for show
it's not substantive I am all for
speaking with our adversaries but what's
happened here is that this president has
raised the profile of a dictator like
Kim Jong hoon and now three times
visited with him unsuccessfully because
he's doing it backward they talk about
historic moments this is historic him
going to North Korea is like Chamberlin
going to talk to Hitler okay well we're
in the presidential campaign season
Jesse so I guess that everybody had to
jump on the bandwagon and for cold water
on but at historic moment the stall the
talks had been stalled the staff member
the president walked away from the last
one and the staffs weren't even talking
to each other and now staff can at least
start talking to each other again
Donald Trump is the peacemaker on the
Korean Peninsula
That's not me who said that one that is
the South Korean president moon a
left-of-centre leader so I just think
everybody needs to be reminded that
people in the region are very
appreciative of what Donald Trump is
doing over there diplomatically listen
it's going to take a long time it's a
process but I think you could
acknowledge everybody can acknowledge
it's heading in the right direction that
direction can change but at this point
no more nuclear testing and our posture
remains strong in the region we just
opened up the largest US military base
in the entire world in South Korea we
have 25,000 military personnel there the
naval fleet is right off the coast and
they're still under the nuclear umbrella
everything that other presidents have
done have not worked it has gotten more
dangerous and more dangerous in North
Korea this president comes along try
something different
he's criticized the entire time the
tweeting the summits one of them which
he walked away from but I think
everybody can agree we're heading in the
right direction there was a thaw and
historians will acknowledge that this
step across the DMZ was a very powerful
and important moment and a symbolic one
Gregg but sometimes you need a symbolic
moment so for everybody to take notice
the other thing that President Trump is
able to do you see got everyone to stop
talking about the democratic debate
which maybe helps the Democrats yeah you
know I don't of course they're going to
attack him that's what you would do and
I and let's be honest if it were the
adversary and adversary Oh from your
party on the other side doing it during
you we would do the same but so I want
to just attack a couple of the
criticisms if you see diplomacy as a
weakness
what does that leave you with we know
that there are tyrants and creeps in
this world you can't hold to thoughts in
your head that there are rough customers
in the world and you got to talk to them
so you could do you can keep those and
and you convinced and your goal is to
remove the psychological barriers or the
threats that are perceived by the
adversary who thinks that maybe you want
to kill them
Trump has removed that he's saying look
we're not that we're not interested in
blowing you up you don't need to have
these these nuclear items but I mean
casting diplomacy as a zero-sum game
we talked to him therefore we lose
something right so what did we lose did
we lose money did we lose land did we
lose lives no well we lost our status in
the world while we've elevated his
status that if that's how you value
these things no wonder we've made no
progress you will never make any
progress because if you keep saying that
the diplomacy causes a loss in status
why have diplomacy at all forget about
it and clearly we are in a better
situation than we were two years ago we
remember what happened what Hawaii
thought that they were gonna you know be
nuked yeah I prefer this to that it's a
sight a detail yeah I think so too
justify yeah Juan do you want to play
Jesse's favorite game oh let's talk to
Cuba oh no this is terrible Oh what
about Iran Oh terrible you know and of
course as you pointed out North Korea
don't do it don't give him that kind of
status on the world stage and trust
Obama though oh I see okay whoever you
support you trust that person the big
issue for me is that Trump's gesture
that which i think is just vanity is
just the photo-op
is not stopping North Korea from getting
nuclear weapons it's not stopping their
missile testing in fact there's now talk
that what the Trump administration's
willing to do is accept North Korea as a
nuclear power that's not true well this
is what the New York Times is reporting
York Times is absolutely right just
they've never been wrong let me just say
that john bolton who was not on the trip
did not come he just said you know what
we haven't talked about in terms of
national scale but of course the
national security team didn't talk about
trump taking a step into North Korea I
would make one last point dinner that
for all of us at his table I think we
were all very sensitive to otto warmbier
and to what his family went through and
the idea that President Trump goes over
there and now is piling around saying
nice things about Kim jong-un who
tortured and I think killed an American
citizen I just think that is so
disrespectful to his memory and to the
face so what you're saying is because of
otto warmbier
you're right we went down hard on what
they did that we should not have any
diplomacy do you think his family's okay
with that I didn't say is okay with that
I didn't say that what I of the United
States giving his in premature but one
here's the thing to you president Trump
could just as easily go back to fire and
fury tomorrow because as we know what
the president he's unpredictable but
what I think he is trying to do is he's
trying to convince Kim jong-un that he
doesn't have to be isolated from the
rest of the world and that nuclear
weapons aren't key to the regime's
survival and I think the most telling
example of this and the most you know
the argument that he's trying to make is
depicted if you watch the video that
President Trump presented Kim jong-un
and in Singapore it's like this really
interesting video that he showed him and
essentially what it does it shows these
diverging paths that North Korea could
go on and one is isolation and
destruction and the other is prosperity
and peace and so that's the argument
that President Trump has continued to
make to North Korea
these are the two paths you have these
are the two choices you have it's either
one or the other and I think everything
we've seen a president Trump trying to
do of late is to encourage diplomacy to
increase the sanctions to try to do
whatever you can to push them into the
corner of peace and prosperity which I
think we should all support they're not
at war with North Korea and they say we
aren't at war with them and we may not
like them we may not like there's a lot
of people that we don't like but
unfortunately we're all stuck on this
earth together and maybe it takes
somebody who has a personal and
persuasion skill set to break this thing
open it seems like it's happening but
it's three meetings right tomorrow you
have don't trust Obama under squirt
the point is you could you can respect
Obama and think he's better in some
things than Trump is but I don't think
he's the right man for this job
Trump had a different skill set to go
and deal with this guy that I don't
think Obama had yeah I mean Obama would
have given him a hundred and fifty
billion dollars cash maybe sure I did
not give him cash try not giving him the
credit way on a serious note what does
this say to Iran as Iran starts to
violate the deal that we abandoned we
think what so they say oh well you do it
to talk with these guys you live in
North Korea I think the president's
trying to get better deals done with the
Iranians and with the North Koreans
because the deals before those didn't
work very well if you actually had
constructive criticism we'd listen okay
so I'm gonna go go all right